american history is filled with great
moments of triumph the bay of pig's
invasion
is not one of them it was an event which
saw the united states aid cuban exiles
in invading cuba with the intent of
overthrowing its new communist ruler
fidel castro
in case you're wondering it failed
miserably but given the sheer disparity
and power between the united states and
cuba how did it fail
surely victory in cuba would have been
easy so first a bit of background
after half a decade of turmoil the cuban
government was overthrown by a communist
revolution and the certain fidel castro
was placed in charge of the country
castro soon seized foreign-owned assets
mostly american and demanded american
troops leave the country
with the exception of guantanamo bay
which was legally not a part of cuba
anymore and so castro had no authority
there
this nationalization of mostly
everything cost american businesses and
the us government a great deal of money
which upset them
what really annoyed them though was that
their old allied neighbor was now
friends with their ideological opponents
in the ussr
as such castro had to go and president
eisenhower ordered the cia to make plans
for the overthrow of the cuban
government
however eisenhower wouldn't get to do
anything about it since his term was up
and in 1960 he was replaced by john f
kennedy who ran on a strong
anti-communist platform
and as such kennedy would have to act on
castro or he'd look like a fool
he was presented with two plans for
overthrowing castro
plan one was for a u.s backed invasion
from the south whereby rebels would
depart from nicaragua and seize trinidad
the cuban city that is not the island
these rebels would then set up a new
government there which the us would then
promptly recognize and support in the
war along with the cuban people who
would inevitably rise up against castro
plan two was for the exiles to land here
in the bay of pigs with very little
direct american assistance
the idea was that they would land secure
a beachhead begin a guerilla war and
then the cuban people would rise up to
support them
kennedy wanted plausible deniability and
so he opted for plan too
the forces landed in cuba and within
three days they'd been completely
defeated
so what went wrong well first of all
kennedy's insistence on having
deniability meant that the cuban exiles
were poorly supported and the 1500 of
them were easily outmatched by cuba's
military
kennedy was in a tough spot if he
directly aided the exiles he'd have
risked upsetting the ussr and escalating
things
and if he'd have done nothing he'd have
looked weak on communism and also the
ussr might have access to america's
front yard
much of the failure was down to the lack
of american air support for the exiles
which would have certainly tipped some
things in their favor
but kennedy even when he knew the
invasion was failing refused to send in
the air force
and the reasons for this were that one
america's previous foray into korea and
its current one in vietnam weren't
exactly proving to be riveting quick
successes
and two the cia had told him that even
without air support they'd expected the
exiles to win since it was inevitable
that the cuban people would rise up
against their communist overlords one
problem though castro was proving to be
quite popular and so the cuban people
were largely outraged at this
foreign-backed invasion and his
popularity sword afterwards
the exiles were all killed or captured
and had the u.s made a greater
contribution they could have potentially
succeeded
although as the cia would soon learn not
with the support of the cuban people
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly moneymaker rob waterhouse moe
marvin cassell
aaron the white jordan longley james
castaneda gustav swan jerry landon
maggie patzkowski copper tone rasheed
ali winston k wood misses it
spinning three plates lexi schwinn
matthew shipley anthony beckett robert
wetzel
marcus arsenault corso wolf spencer
lightfoot and charles the first